[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
émission spéciale ce débat pour
l'entre-deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle pour cette émission est
la rédaction de tv fil 78 conviant
plateau didier baichère le coordinateur
du mouvement en marche dans les yvelines
et françois simeoni le président
départemental du front national bonsoir
à vous deux deux thématiques
au programme ce soir pour connaître les
idées de votre candidat respectif sur
les collectivités territoriales et les
banlieues mais pour débuter ce débat je
vous propose messieurs est d'écouter
chacun votre tour un habitant de saint
quentin en yvelines qui vous posent
directement une question première
interrogation pour vous françois simeoni
didier baichère vous pourrez réagir
ensuite qu'est ce qu'il compte faire
pour les toutes petites entreprises les
entreprises qui emploie localement qui
diffuse localement et qui essayent de
survivre
que ce soit au niveau agricole ou au
niveau industriel ou commercial
alors la réponse à cette interrogation
sur cette problématique locale
je crois savoir que le front national va
principalement agir sur les charges
c'est ça ça fait partie des dix mesures
prioritaires que marine prendra une fois
arrivée à l'elysée elle compte diminuer
les abaisser les charges en transférant
le cic eux les 50 milliards sur la sur
les petites et moyennes entreprises afin
de procéder donc cette diminution des
charges est essentielle parce qu'on sait
très bien que c'est ce qui l'a la
vitalité de ces
les entreprises qui sont véritablement
mines d'emplois très importante en
france à didier baichère en marche aussi
veut agir sur le coût du travail vous
proposez aussi de votre côté de baisser
les charges des entreprises
oui il ya la fois les charges pour les
salariés parce qu'il faut aussi que les
salariés puissent gagner du pouvoir
d'achat dans ce set histoire et la
baisse des charges pour l'ensemble des
entreprises
donc c'est la pérennisation du cic eux
qui est transformé en baisse de charge
la question était sur les petites
entreprises
moi je pense aux commerçants aux
artisans également et là la vraie
nouveauté avec emmanuel macron c'est
qu'on va voir le chômage universel donc
la liberté l'énergie d'entreprendre va
être très présente puisque aujourd'hui
les artisans les commerçants par exemple
ou les indépendants qui sont seuls dans
une toute petite entreprise n'avait pas
cette sécurité du chômage ils l'auront
avec manu mâcon on passe à la question
désormais qui vous est destiné puis
françois simoni vous pourrez réagir
aussi alors monsieur macron comment
comptez vous améliorer le sort de ceux
qui ont le smic pour vivre et de ceux
qui n'ont même pas le smic pour vivre
alors évidemment vous n'êtes pas
emmanuel macron mais vous êtes son
représentant local
mais pour les personnes les plus
fragiles financièrement qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que le candidat en marche
espère espère faire s'il est élu
évidemment sur les berges de charges
c'est un très bon exemple puisque ont
annoncé base essentiellement sur les
rémunérations au niveau du smig
l'équivalent alors le cumul de l'arrêt
des cotisations maladie plus l'arrêt des
cotisations chômage qui seront supprimés
dès des cotisations des fiches de paye
des salariés plus l'augmentation de la
prime pour l'emploi fait l'équivalent
d'un treizième mois pour l'ensemble des
salariés
au niveau du smic donc il ya un gain de
pouvoir d'achat c'est à peu près peu
plus de 100 euros par mois qui concerne
ses salariés il ya vraiment un focus qui
est fait sur le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés avec une rémunération la plus
basse françois simoni pour le front
national c'est une thématique souvent
souvent mise en avant pour par marine le
pen
il ya non seulement parce que il faut
redonner du pouvoir d'achat ou plus
faibles et notamment de retraités je
suis surpris que vous ayez pas parler de
l'eau
mentation de la csg que vous leur
réserve et nous c'est directement une
baisse de 10% des trois premières
tranches d'impôt sur le revenu
si la personne qui posait la question et
veuves pour les veufs et veuves
on a un rétablissement de la demi part
automatiquement une défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires et une baisse
immédiate de 5% des tarifs régulés
d'énergie et de gaz un vouliez peut-être
réagir sur la csg ou on passe tout de
suite puisque vous êtes on va jeter un
coup d'oeil pour le pour le chronomètre
vous êtes en avance pour pour en marche
je crois je crois savoir une 0,7 pour en
marche et pour le front national et une
minute 0 une pour le pour le front
national voilà les chronomètres
s'affiche à l'instant que vous êtes sûr
à un temps imparti est ce que voulait
répondre à ça tout de suite ou la série
d'assiettes de la csg effectivement sauf
pour les retraités avec une retraite les
plus faibles puisque 40% des des
retraités seront pas concerné par ça
j'ajoute quand même les vous 80 plus
faible masse et la retraite moyenne
c'est à 1600 euros donc c'est jusque là
1300 euros de retraite qui ne seront pas
concernées par l'élargissement de la csg
j'ajoute on a quand même aussi
80% des habitants un des françaises et
des français qui paieront plus la taxe
d'habitation c'est aussi souvent qu'on
voit en parlait justement puisque notre
premier thématique concerne les
collectivités territoriales le
quinquennat de françois hollande a été
marquée on le sait par la réduction du
nombre de régions de 22 à 13 des légions
qui ne trouve aucune grâce aux yeux du
front national marine le pen veut passer
à trois échelons les communes les
départements et l'état bon concrètement
si marine le pen est élue
fini les régions aient fini les
intercommunalités alors rétablissons le
vrai vraies propositions de marine ce
sujet il s'agit pas de supprimer les
régions des régions sont essentielles il
a su il s'agit de supprimer le niveau
administratif correspondant au conseil
régional c'est pas la même chose
il ya eu pléthore de niveaux
d'administration qui ont été créés
l'écho comme les communautés
d'agglomération comme les conseils
régionaux et nous nous proposons
uniquement trois niveaux
d'administration la commune
le département et l'état pour des
raisons simples des raisons de tout
simplement de de simplification
administrative parce qu'on a vu en
siégeant dans les collectivités
territoriales avec monsieur v cher et on
sait très bien la complexité de
transfert de compétences entre la la
commune la communauté d'agglomération
ont fait travailler des des
fonctionnaires territoriaux pendant des
heures et des heures pour des calculs
bien complexe oh pas grand chose donc
pour des raisons de simplification qu'on
supprime les communautés d'agglomération
pour des raisons de proximité ou six
parce que les gens bien évidemment un
contact il ya beaucoup plus simple avec
le nerf qu'avec le qu'avec la communauté
d'agglomération et bien sûr pour des
raisons d'économie parce que ça fait
aussi pléthore de d'indemnités aux élus
dont on peut franchement se passe ce qui
veut dire concrètement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui puisque c'est le
territoire sur lequel on travaille à
téléfilm 118 va être amenée à
disparaître
la wicca à perdre deux de ses pouvoirs
la communauté d'agglomération dont elle
va est effectivement ne plus exister et
on va redonner aux communes les
compétences qu'elle avait un transfert
de compétences à la fois vers les
communes et dans le département
ce qui somme toute vous savez ce qu'on
dit souvent pour les communautés
d'agglomération est-ce que j'ai souvent
l'occasion de dire à la communauté de
versailles grand parc où je siège à part
gérer le conservatoire de musique
les pistes cyclables et la distribution
de poule la communauté de versailles
grand parc ne fait pas grand chose
didier baichère emmanuel macron et est
un petit peu moins on va dire radical
dans ses propositions il propose lui de
réduire de 25% le nombre de départements
d'ici 2022 est ce qu'on sait déjà les
départements qui vont être amenées à
disparaître d'ici là le sujet il est de
quel territoire ont pas et emmanuel
macron est très clair quand il dit
l'échelon du département est extrêmement
important plus on s'approche de la
ruralité qu'on va être loin de
territoires plus plus compact c'est
intéressant cet exemple de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de
versailles grand parc parce que
finalement on voit là un territoire j'ai
envie de dire comme saint-quentin qui
est historique et qui est aboutie et un
territoire comme
grand parc est finalement assez jeune et
comme le dit monsieur simeoni qui peut
être aujourd'hui se cherche encore et ne
va pas au bout de sa volonté politique
ne va peut-être pas au bout de sa
volonté politique parce qu'il n'y a pas
de volonté politique de développer
versailles grand parc
moi je je je vois
saint-quentin-en-yvelines j'ai habité au
très longtemps avant d'habiter
versailles il ya réellement de la mise
en commun d'équipement il ya de la
réellement de la mise en commun sur sur
les transports donc je pense que pour
les familles de saint quentin en
yvelines il ya un gain extrêmement
intéressant en termes de cohérence de
territoire d'être sur 50 ans et ses
départements c'est 25% comment on sera à
fait le choix ce sera la volonté n'est
justement des séquences aussi si vous
regardez la région parisienne entre le
dispositif de la région ile de france et
des départements qui sont limitrophes 1
qui appartiennent à la région ile de
france il ya probablement des choses qui
se superposent et qui ne sont pas très
efficaces alors dans le programme en
marche vous souhaitez également donnée
au préfet la capacité d'adapter
l'organisation des services de l'état
aux besoins de chaque région et
département est ce que vous pouvez nous
exclure et là dessus sur quelles
problématiques
ça va ça va répondre c'est d'aller au
bout de la décentralisation qui s'est un
petit peu arrêté quelque part il ya
quelques années on voit bien que ce qui
marche c'est ce qui est au plus proche
des territoires
et quand on dit redonner du pouvoir aux
collectivités locales redonner du
pouvoir aux préfets
c'est quand il ya de l'expérimentation
et quand il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent sur un territoire leur
donner l'opportunité de le mettre en
place ne pas attendre tout de l'état qui
souvent est très très loin des
préoccupations quotidiennes des français
sur ces territoires au fonds national
vous souhaitez vous renforcez
précisément le rôle des maires des
petites et moyennes communes c'est pour
répondre là aussi à une problématique de
distance entre le citoyen et et ses élus
tout à fait raison bien simple de
proximité des avants la ville à la
fusion des départements telle qu'elle
est prévue actuellement qui est initié
d'ailleurs sur les sur les yvelines
entre les yvelines 92 par monsieur
pierre bédier et monsieur devedjian qui
travaille depuis depuis longtemps arrive
à une des communautés d'agglomération
qui n'ont plus de sens qui sont
gigantesques
ou bien évidemment les personnes ne
pourront nous n'aurons plus de contacts
avec l'essentiel qui est le contact
direct avec son maire déjà ses dix
erreurs et ils vont difficile désertes
dans les grandes communes mais ça ça va
complètement disparaître
moi je voudrais revenir sur lui sur le
la pseudo économie de la suppression de
taxe d'habitation merci à ces sites
alors ça serait 80% des français d'ici
2020 2022 qui seraient exonérés de la
taxe d'habitation ça c'est urgent 40%
sont déjà exonérées sachant qatar %
sidéré pour nous c'est une véritable
supercherie dans le sens où on sait très
bien que les taxes d'habitation se sont
touchés par les communes l'excès
communes ont été déjà que fortement
touché par la baisse des dotations de
l'état sous le gouvernement socialiste
elles ont eu du mal à compenser cette
baisse donc si on leur enlève les taxes
d'habitation elles vont bien évidemment
trouver une autre un autre moyen pour
être financées sinon c'est la mort des
communes là vous avez un peu de temps
avance sur le temps de parole vous
souhaitez peut-être répondre 7
à cette interrogation mise en avant sur
la taxe d'habitation moins d'argent pour
les communes c'est évalué à 10 milliards
d'euros je crois non mais c'est pas
moins d'argent pour les communes cère
que l'engagement il est très clair c'est
que pour les contribuables
il n'y a plus cette taxe est donc c'est
du pouvoir d'achat pour eux l'état
garantit intégralement le fonds qui
étaient de ceux enfin qui est donné aux
communes il n'est pas question d'aller
diminuer d'autant le budget des communes
ciblées shirts et pas cher alors c'est
l'état qui paye puisque vous dites en
thaïlande et économiques nous ferons
ailleurs je rappelle que notre projet
global 10 à 50 milliards d'économies
un sujet en tout cas qui inquiète pour
continuer dans ce débat qui inquiète
beaucoup les élus et qui joue à la
hausse parfois sur les impôts locaux
c'est la baisse des dotations globales
de financement elles sont elles ont
fortement chuté depuis 2014
pour y remédier par exemple on prend un
exemple département des yvelines a
augmenté l'an passé de 66 % sa taxe
foncière
emmanuel macron va demander un nouvel
effort de 10 milliards d'euros sur cinq
ans aux collectivités territoriales vous
estimer qu'elles peuvent encore le faire
aujourd'hui tout dépend du plan de
transformation qu'on leur propose
aujourd'hui on dit les services publics
qui doivent évoluer et doit être au plus
près des français
si on veut poursuivre la numérisation
des services publics beaucoup d'actions
peuvent être faites
grâce à la numérisation le plan de
numérotation du service public
aujourd'hui n'est pas aboutie donc
évidemment il s'agit pas de baisser pour
baisser il ya des arbitrages veut dire
sur le département qui ont été faits
plus de manière un peu violente sans
regarder exactement de quoi il allait
être question à quels allaient être les
conséquences on n'est pas du tout dans
cette approche là on a dit une baisse
associer un plan de transformation des
communes qui seront qui seront
raccompagnés emmanuel macron à
d'ailleurs précisé qu'il y aurait une
conférence tous les six mois entre le
premier ministre et les différents
représentants des communes pour pouvoir
évaluer l'avancement de ce plan de
transformation
donc on lâche pas les communes comme ça
françois simoni pour conclure sur cette
première thématique quel est le point de
vue du front national sur les efforts
encore éventuellement demander aux
collectivités territoriales vous allez
un an de plus aussi non je pense que
c'est 30 secondes c'est si on reste sur
cette logique si on reste sur leur
logique il a qu'une seule solution c'est
dérégulé c'est à dire supprimer des
fonctionnaires d'une part et d'autre
part augmenter les impôts ils n'ont pas
d'autres possibilités et donc le front
national nous avons une d'autres
d'autres solutions parce que nous
remettons en cause ce qui est ce qui est
leur fondement et et on peut en
remettant en cause des fondamentaux
changer complètement de politique 1,1
point sur vos temps de parole respectifs
avant de basculer sur notre deuxième
thématique françois simeoni on le voit à
l'écran vous êtes à 4 minutes 15 et
didier baichère vous êtes à trois
minutes 52 donc un petit peu de retard
on va du coup débuté avec vous et cette
nouvelle thématique les quartiers
populaires généralement les plus
fragiles là où le chômage et la pauvreté
sont le plus important ce sont ces
quartiers qui ont généralement qui
exprime le plus de besoin
quelles sont les priorités des manuels
macron pour ces quartiers populaires
alors qu'on sait que les problèmes
touchent évidemment l'emploi l'éducation
l'accès à la santé au logement au
transport
quelles sont les priorités pour emmanuel
macron tous ces sujets donc c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué de en 30 secondes de
résumer mais je pense que si on prend
une mesure emblématique
il ya par exemple la création d emplois
francs dire que on a essayé pendant des
années d'aider d'accompagner des
entreprises pour qu'ils aillent
s'installer dans les quartiers dits
ici ça ne marche pas donc qu'est-ce
qu'on dit on va inverser la vapeur et on
va proposer entre entreprises qui
embaucheraient des salariés qui habitent
ces quartiers dits difficiles de leur
proposer une prime d'accompagnement
15000 euros sur trois ans quand on
embauche quelqu'un en cdi
c'est l'équivalent de la suppression de
la totalité des charges pour pour ces
personnes là voilà donc c'est essayer de
faire des choses qui n'ont pas existé en
matière de formation c'est pareil quand
on regarde le budget qui est consacré à
la formation sur 100 euros dépensés en
formation seulement 15 euros va aux
demandeurs d'emploi sinon si l'emploi
est difficile l'accès à l'emploi
difficile dans ces quartiers c'est aussi
parce que l'orientation n'a pas été la
bonne
vous pourrez remonter sur l'éducation il
ya aussi des mesures dans ce domaine là
mais il faut réinvestir du budget de
formation sur les dormants d'emploi pour
les former vers les nouveaux métiers
je remonte très rapidement vers
l'éducation si on a eu des
problématiques d'orientation à un moment
donné c'est parce qu'on a abandonné ce
sujet là au niveau de l'école et donc ça
on veut réinvestir le sujet de
l'orientation comme une vraie matière
d'enseignement à l'école pour donner de
la prédiction d'emploi correct
enfin par les enseignants pour les
élèves
et puis n'oublions pas que tout en amont
on propose de ramener les classes de cp
et de ce1 dans ces quartiers dits
difficiles à seulement douze élèves
parce que l'apprentissage du français
des mathématiques doit se faire
correctement du coup avec des embauches
massives de
2000 enseignants oui douze mille
enseignants qui seront affectés en
priorité à ces fameuses classes cp ce1
et aux quartiers difficiles douze élèves
maximum par par enseignant qu'elle est
quelle est la proposition du front
national sur cette thématique là des
quartiers populaires on sait que le
front national est souvent porté sur la
thématique de la sécurité c'est d'abord
rétablir la sécurité dans ces
quartiers-là votre priorité ou alors
c'est autre chose quand nous pensons
qu'il n'existe qu'une seule communauté
la communauté nationale et de vouloir
faire de la discrimination positive
pour certains c'est forcément faire de
la discrimination négative pour d'autres
donc ce n'est pas notre façon de voir
les choses
nous analysons en fait dans ces
quartiers difficiles qu'on a laissé que
le système ait l'air ps à laisser se
détériorer pendant depuis depuis des
années et des années
deux problèmes essentiels le chômage de
masse et l'insécurité
par ailleurs nous sommes persuadé qu' il
existe des forces vives dans ces
quartiers et ses forces vives ne peuvent
pas se développer parce qu'elles sont
censurés censuré par des problèmes liés
à la vie de tous les jours
difficile lié à l'islamisme qui impose
une certaine façon de se vêtir une
certaine façon de se comporter et qui
est une pesanteur sur ces quartiers et
c'est la ceinture et activiste de voyage
dans les quartiers populaires alors le
chômage dans les quartiers populaires
est une est une réalité mais c'est à une
réalité nationale et pour sortir de
cette réalité
encore une fois il faut remettre en
cause les fondamentaux qui sont ceux du
système actuel c'est à dire vouloir
rester dans l'union européenne
et avec tout c'est plus que ça entraîne
au niveau de notre perte de
compétitivité mais il faut différencier
ce qui est mesures immédiates de ski et
mesures à long terme pour les mesures
immédiates pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat comme je les dis on peut baisser
les impôts de 10 % baisser le coût de
l'électricité et du gaz
réguler réglementaire de 5 % fallait des
mesures qui permettent de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat à tous les besoins ça
vous n'êtes pas de politiques
spécifiques à certaines zones certains
territoires en france
bien évidemment nous nous reconnaissons
que la communauté nationale
le tient encore à rappeler l'article 3
des statuts du front national qui dit
que les français sont égaux quelle que
soit leur origine le coureur de poules
religion vous parliez tout à l'heure
d'éducation pour évoquer voici votre
programme peut être sûr sur l'éducation
même si là aussi il n'y a pas de
décrochage particulier pour les
quartiers populaires vous proposez vous
que 50% du temps à l'école primaire soit
consacrée uniquement à la pratique du
français
nous considérons qu effectivement dans
le primaire il faut recentrer sur les
fondamentaux avec effectivement 50%
réservé à l'enseignement du français et
le reste étant consacré essentiellement
aux calculs afin que les élèves puissent
sortir du primaire avec connaissons bien
les bases de la langue et du calcul
la proposition qui est qui est faite par
monsieur mes chers et et son équipe de
renouveler les douze élèves maximum par
classe et les amène à de manière
évidente un coup au niveau de
recrutement des enseignants qui n'a pas
pu être en place par madame vallaud
belkacem qui a largement contribué à la
destruction du système éducatif en
france nous pensons qu'il faut redonner
une véritable école de la république
avec des moyens mais aussi avec une
volonté de redonner un enseignant sont
cc ses qualités de d'enseignants de
formation et aussi de discipline
je pense que c'est essentiel et redonner
aux diplômes leur valeur didier bêchage
que vous souhaitiez réagir à ce qui est
ce qui vient d'être dit éventuellement
oui bon on souhaite en tout cas réussir
là où effectivement l'équipe précédente
a échoué parce que il est aussi question
de remettre en place les classes
bilangues de remettre l'enseignement du
latin en place pour qu'on ait ces
fondamentaux de la langue française
il est question aussi de laisser les
maires se remettre autour de la table
pour travailler sur les rythmes
scolaires à ne pas avoir des positions
dogmatiques et aussi peut-être quelques
parce que monsieur simeoni oublie aussi
que dans le programme de madame le pen
il ya la préférence nationale
donc moi j'aimerais bien savoir comment
on va faire la préférence nationale
quand on est une entreprise pour
recruter des gens quand on sait vous
êtes si on prend deux exemples extrêmes
le bâtiment des sociétés de conseil et
de service que je connais bien puisque
je fais des rêves une entreprise de
secteurs où on embauche des gens de
toutes les nationalités
pas juste parce qu'il n'ya pas de
travailleurs français parce qu'on a
besoin de leurs compétences
alors donc je ne vois pas comment on
mettra en place cette préférence
nationale si ce n'est à faire du délit
de faciès mais qui déclenchera la haine
est probablement la guerre civile
d'abord parce que vous êtes vraiment en
avance françois simani vous souhaitez
réagir puis on va passer une dernière
thématique
oui on sait très bien que les
entreprises notamment de bâtiments
profite actuellement des travailleurs
détachés
si c'est ça la dérégulation du monde 32
travail voulue par les socialistes
je vois pas où est la protection du
travailleur français vous souhaitez oui
d'ailleurs vous noterez qu emmanuel
macron a clairement parlé de ça le jour
de la fête du travail
c'était c'était le premier mais bien
entendu il a parlé qu'il faudrait
regarder comment faire évoluer cette
directive sur les travailleurs détachés
parce qu'elle est incompréhensible pour
les français
donc on va s'y attellent s'y atteler
mais comme on va s'atteler aussi à être
de nouveau le moteur de l'europe
on va jeter pénétrer un dernier coup
d'oeil sur les chronomètres si possible
au sinon on fera un point dans dans
quelques secondes
là dessus les chronomètres vont
s'afficher justement à l'écran tout de
suite donc sept minutes 22 pour vous
françois signé françois nationale et
6,32
pour didier baichère donc ça vous laisse
une plus longue conclusion on va
commencer par vous françois simoni sur
sept abstentions dont on ne connaît
forcément pas le taux à l'avance mais
qui risque d'être importante
malheureusement sur ce qu'ont lancé pour
l'instant qu'est ce que vous dites à
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas forcément
aller voter dimanche prochain
alors moi je leur demande de s'engager
sincèrement je parlerai delà des
représentants de la gauche insoumise
je leur demande d'aller voter contre le
candidat de la finance et qui est pour
la dérégulation du monde du travail
notamment qu'il veut pas abroger la loi
qui brille et pour les électeurs de
droite
je leur demande de s'engager aussi
contre cinq gouvernements socialistes
qui avec toutes ces dérives sociétal que
l'on connaît l'augmentation des impôts
qui va inévitablement arrivée didier
baichère pour pour la conclusion je
précise que vous aviez ouvert à ce débat
donc vous concluez pour de l'équité vous
avez un peu plus de temps sur certains
conclusions sur l'abstention
je crois qu'on peut comprendre
l'inquiétude des habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines en fait des yvelines
de manière générale face à face à cette
élection je crois qu'il faut pas se
tromper d'élection aujourd'hui on est
face à l'élection du président de la
république qui va diriger la france
pendant cinq ans on n'est pas aux
élections législatives et donc
aujourd'hui on a le choix entre le
programmes des manuels macron qui se
veut un programme de rassemblement
d'ouverture de replacer la france au
coeur de l'europe et de pilotage de
l'europe d'avancer sur un certain nombre
de thématiques comme le pouvoir d'achat
pour pour les français donc laissé place
ou laisser voter les autres ça nous
semble vraiment une idée extrêmement
dangereuse donc chacun doit voter
dimanche en son âme et conscience
s'abstenir ou voter blanc
c'est faire le jeu
marine le pen donc je ne suis pas sûr
que c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
maintenant alors avant de vous dire au
revoir peut-être afficher les
chronomètres une dernière fois pour
peut-être constaté que vous avez un peu
de retard didier baichère oui voilà
quelques quelques secondes que nous
récupérerons évidemment dans le reste de
la semaine pour une question d'équité
c'est la fin de cette émission spéciale
dédiée au débat local de l'entre-deux
tours de la présidentielle merci à vous
d'être venu en plateau didier baichère
pour en marche et françois simoni pour
le front national vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application téléphiles
78 et n'oubliez pas que lundi prochain
la rédaction de tv fils vous propose une
édition spéciale pour revenir sur les
résultats du second tour et notamment
sur le département est désir line bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]